tiếp tục nân cao chất lợng mòn tiện thật chế tổ chức thiền phóc lợt và đọc của các tự quan tư phán.
Phóc lợt với đó gàng của định khả thì mình bài dưới thực hiện dưới kiểm tra dưới răm sát.
Điều trao phải giữa trên chứng cứ khách quan khoà.
Điện tự dưới lợt, công tổ kiểm tra phát, phải chặt chế khách quan sẽ sử phương của nằm bởi đóclup.
Chỉ tôn theo phóc lợt nân cao tính thứ phụ của bạn ảm.
Thì anh anh phải được call lợt khu quy định hiểu lực thực tế của công li.
Cuyểm sát chất chế quyền lực từ pháp phòng chống tiêu cực trong hỏa động từ pháp.
Đồng thời xây rực đợc mù cám bộ từ pháp điểm chính bản lýnh trên nghiệp.
Và đây mạnh từ pháp số của anh chỉ cái cách từ pháp mong giữ lợt.
Bởi hoàn thiện cơ chiế phòng ngờ phát hiện sửi, cái hành vi càn thiệp trái pháp lợt.
Cuyểm sát xuống đợt lợt lợt.
Mình mạnh phân công an.
Giám định điện ra đấu ra thì anh anh sẽ đi nghiêm trải hành.
Môi dưới anh làm sai lệnh phòng sơ lợt giúp chứ cụ nhan trong hỏa động từ pháp.
Đúng đại hổ sơ đi tởi tự.
Chứng cứ đến tởi công khai bản an, quản li an, mạnh giữ lợt, lên thông giữ lợt,
sẽ cơ quan từ pháp với cách tì cơ sởi lợt của anh.